50 Euro wenn du Sandra direkt killst
ich bin wie so ein Trüffelschwein
ich habe es gesehen du kleiner Wixxer
und das waren
[Musik]
wirklich 50 Euro donated gerade
[Applaus]
[Musik]
du bist auch schon da
oh no haben
ja dafür sind wir alle hingefahren was
hältst du davon
ja wenn wir ein Schaf mitnehmen
bei uns auf die Insel packen können und
dass die dann dass wir dann scharf
nachher jepp nennen können und dann
machen wir das so
regenbogenmäßig wisst ihr weißt du was
du machen könntest du bräuchtest
eigentlich ein zweites Schaf Sandy damit
du lieber ein paar kannst du dann kannst
du immer mehr Schafe weißt du
[Musik]
soll ich den Kompass geben und ein Boot
und du suchst ja auf der Insel hinten
noch das zweite Schaf
ja dann gib
also Leute meine prank Idee ist dass ich
Sandras Haus komplett abbaue und ein
Block weiter nach rechts setze und dann
schauen wir ob es ihr auffällt
mehr Leute ich muss es jetzt lassen wir
lassen es jetzt so wir schauen mal ob
sie es merkt weil wenn sie reingeht es
ist schon ein bisschen anders jetzt hier
mehr Platz aber das jetzt gleich das ist
gleich wir haben jetzt quasi Sanders
Haus genommen und verschoben einfach
eine Ewigkeit später was
gemacht
haben
was
anders
[Musik]
aus und du hast ganz sicherlich nichts
an meinem Haus gemacht
ich habe übrigens Leute wurde ich auf
tiktok ähm markiert wie ich quasi das
keine Monster mehr kommen und das mache
ich heute ich brauche ungefähr 600
Lampen
oh Fackeln damit keiner mehr kommt warum
denn 600 Fackeln das wirst Du schon früh
genug erkennen was ich davor habe und
während seiner sich da ihre komischen
Fackeln macht werde ich jetzt den Job
prank machen hast du mal wieder die
Schafe geschert
dafür habe ich jetzt keine Zeit
jetzt mache ich hier den prank mit Champ
und sie sagt sie hat keine Zeit um sich
die Schafe anzuschauen und zu scheren
weil sie ihre verdammten Fackeln hier
überall hinsetzen muss weil so kommen
die nicht die werden trotzdem kommen
einfach von woanders werden sie nicht
ich werde mal komplettes Haus umzingeln
und auch auf dem Weg Sandra
ja
pack deine hässlichen Lichter von meinem
schönen Weg
was ist denn das
Sandra
[Musik]
warum darf ich auf tiktok so gesehen
wieso ist unsere
schafwechselt die Farbe was hast du
gemacht mit dem Schaf ich habe das was
du was soll ich denn machen dass das die
Farbe wechselt einfach nur du hä was
soll ich denn da machen
du baust nicht doch mehr von diesen
hässlichen Fackeln dahin ich will die
auf mein Dach haben Sandra findest du
wirklich dass das hier schön aussieht
es geht hier nicht um Schönheit
minecraft ist ein überlebensspiel der
Typ hat bestimmt nicht sein ganzes Haus
voll geklatscht damit
ja hat er auch gezeigt was er nach einer
Zeit passieren kann nein
ja dass das Feuer über schweigt Diode
deswegen nicht auf den Weg ich will
nicht dass mein Weg anfängt zu brennen
oder mein Haus
[Musik]
guck mal ich kann da durchlaufen
passiert nicht wir tun jetzt so als ob
das Feuer von den Fackeln rüber gekommen
ist auf die Haut tiktok hat noch mehr
gemacht
oh mein Gott
immer wieder
passieren jetzt nicht
[Musik]
okay okay ich versuche so zu löschen ich
habe es gesehen du lenkst das Feuer du
legst das Feuer ich hab's doch gesehen
Du hast Hausverbot ich bin immer noch
überzeugt du hast nicht mal mehr ein
Haus ja meine Bruchbude das kann genauso
bleiben
oh mein Gott
verloren
nein ein Ding ist gestorben Sandy
ein scharfes gestorben ich hatte
gebraten das Hammelfleisch
du weißt nicht du solltest lieber Rennen
[Musik]
das war der größte Fehler deines Lebens
glaub es mir
[Musik]
ja dicker er ist so ein oh mein
Gott
[Applaus]
du machst mich so melden
[Musik]
ich habe ihr gesagt ich habe es gesagt
Leute wenn sie diesen Papagei töten wird
ist für mich alles egal
[Musik]
so das ist Lukas Gesicht ne das ist
Lukas Gesicht ne stellt euch das
imaginär vormachen dicker
habt ihr das alle gesehen genauso würde
ich mit seinem Kopf jetzt machen wäre
ich noch in Köln
patrick's Day heute ja Sandy muss den
Papagei holen und ich bau alles wieder
auf das war der dir ja deswegen Kompass
fahren Dschungel
komm schnell komm schnell ja warte ich
bringe mit
hallo 2.0
geil einfach
Papagei hier sind zweiter Papageien
grüner komm wo bist du denn komm hier um
die Ecke springen ins Wasser springen
ins Wasser
yeah schaut euch das an wir haben beide
ein Papageien
und da haben wir wieder
als wenn nie etwas passiert wäre dann
das Haus
steht mehr oder weniger wieder guck mal
ich zeig dir mal eben kurz in dein Haus
ich habe jetzt erstmal so gemacht
grob ist alles wieder da ich habe die
hier Durchgang gemacht zum schafsding ja
hatte ich auch ganz scharfe wieder rein
machen hier habe ich das
jetzt mal komplett zugemacht und den
katzenstall Weg denn jetzt kann man von
hier halt einfach rein weißt du wo ist
mein Pferdehof noch nicht da alles klar
Whirlpool gemacht und äh Stall bin ich
jetzt wie gesagt noch nicht zu gekommen
weil da werde ich jetzt mich mal ein
bisschen informieren was man da machen
kann weil er 94% mein wir sollen neuen
Stall bauen aber gut Leute an der Stelle
würden wir dann tatsächlich den Stream
für heute auch beenden also Leute Kuss
danke schön für eure Support danke schön
für den extrem geilen Stream würde
extrem lustigen Stream wir sehen uns die
Tage wieder folgt mir am besten einfach
auf Twitch hier ist kostenlos und dann
[Musik]
dann kriege ich den Benachrichtigungen